that's why i am people like tachsinn 1
Heavy,
which at the moment very very much
He does work for it with his social media contributions.
the last
actually simply colored out a strategy,
namely 3 points
for people withMigrationshintergrund,
when they are then deported.
where the best places of refuge are.
1st
they go eat with Hans in happiness or in the
and best order
some with pork,
so that you think,
that they are German.
2ndly,
membership in the AfD.
there he has at the AfD federal office
called and asked,
OB one also as a human being withMigrationshintergrund
can also become a member.
his 3rd proposal
his 3rd proposal had been the coronation,
namely with his mother.
namely,
because I assume that,
that the mother is really good with the
can throw so-called terlik.
now this is a task for them to see what 1.
Terlik is.
I assume that this is the best defense,
when they are
Fantasies then sometime in this country
would want to get through.
but that will never happen,
because the democracies and democrats in this House
will stick together for so long,
that they will never again,
will never have anything to say again,
because we will not allow 1933 happiness on!